ce que j'avais connu en 1992 et presque
tous disparu les derniers témoins de
cette époque aventureuse jeu pouvait les
compter sur les doigts d'une seule main
c'est à 90 ans qu'on fait ce constat
cruel qu'il n'y a plus personne de votre
génération autour de soi à l'âge de 48
ans j'ai dû apprendre à être un
vieillard
[Musique]
il ya un avant et après 7 minutes 49 je
voulais aussi essayé d'autres fins de
tenter de faire ressentir aux lecteurs
ce ce temps qui s'écoule seconde après
seconde
[Musique]
une minute 49 secondes pourquoi mais
parce que c'est tout simplement le temps
très court qui s'est écoulé entre
l'arrivée des assaillants dans les
locaux de charlie et leur sortie il a
fallu trois ou quatre années de
réflexion de gestation de réflexion
personnelle pour le dirait il voir un
peu clair et pour tenter de décrire
quelque chose de lisible aussi qu'ils
soient aussi compréhensible pour le plus
grand nombre puisque la difficulté c'est
comment transmettre aux lecteurs le
chaos et le désordre
[Musique]
quand on est victime de violence dans un
premier temps on a envie de de tourner
le dos à cette violence et de ne plus en
parler mais autour de soi on voit de
toutes sortes de gens qui parlent de
l'événement puisse un manque un
retentissement énorme donc à la fin on
se dit mais finalement il ya des choses
que j'ai ressenti que j'ai vécu dont
personne ne parle
[Musique]
parce que j'ai envie que l'électro
tienne c'est c'est beaucoup de choses
très diverse très variés et c'est de
leur faire sentir la sensation du chaos
qu'on ressent quand on vit un événement
comme ça quand on subit un événement
comme ça et c'est cet inconfort de se
retrouver vivant au milieu des morts on
se dit pourquoi on est vivants pourquoi
les autres ne le sont plus et on est en
fait écartelée entre
la vie qui à nouveau là et la mort des
autres autour de vous qui est aussi là
qu'il sera toujours avec avec nous
[Musique]